Well, the answer is that changing hand_rank wouldn't help anything
because it really is a tie, and hand_rank really does return the same value.
If we both have straight flushes ace high,
hand_rank should return exactly the same thing for both.
Just because we have different suits doesn't mean they should have a different hand_rank.
But we could change poker to return
a list of everybody that tied rather than arbitrarily choose one of them.
Or we could invent a new function, say,
we might want the function "pokerwithties."
So either of those would be okay.
I think the best is not to introduce this new function
because once we have that, who would really want the poker function?
Who would want to say "Let's play a game of poker
where we don't do ties correctly?"
I think we really want to handle ties correctly,
so I think that's the best approach of the 3,
but either approach would do.